on this episode I tell you how you can
be in my next book
[Music]
[Music]
everybody this is gary vay-ner-chuk and
this is episode one to four of the
askgaryvee show my stomach hurts we
could start with that which is rarity I
feel like I'm a machine but once in a
blue moon it happens once it's once
every hundred twenty four episodes you
know
oh god my stomach is killing me I mean
this coffee's not gonna help but I'm
really excited sorry by yesterday was
planning on doing the show but got
caught up in a meeting which I really
enjoyed yesterday i sat down with the
all the interns from the summer and
you're like you have some you filmed
right she'll show like I don't know it's
hard because you just love your kids so
much like you know as much as I want to
talk [ __ ] and be like I'm I'm not gonna
do anything I'm gonna [ __ ] fly them
on private planes right like and there's
a part of me that thinks that I'm
subconsciously doing that on purpose so
they're not better than me and it's
really dark and but I don't you want to
get into that [ __ ] that's the dark part
of my brain but the truth is the truth
is it's just hard right and we really
enjoyed it ran a little long because I
started a little late with them and so
decided to see that through and so
obviously we missed it but today we are
back nice and early here so there should
be out very early in the afternoon you
know right around noon very very early
earlier than ever and and so that's it
so India is this a new shirt for you
that's very nice India let's get into
the show the show I think I know you
were wrong again I'm not sick anymore
I'm rejuvenated by the camera India come
on you should know that by now
show Fabien asks I have a family-owned
grocery store we are starting an online
store tips on getting up and running oh
this is interesting this is very much
deja vu 20 years ago
first and foremost you need to find the
right kind of infrastructure backbone
CMS tool to really get you guys to
launch a content management system CMS
you know Magento or Shopify or one of
these kind of platforms that can get you
up and running in the retail capacity at
a low cost
I would also highly highly think about
how you're going to promote within your
store to drive people to the dot-com I
think a lot of people forget about that
aspect obviously you have to learn how
to do you know Google search ads SEM and
you've got to work on search SEO and
organic you've got to figure out how to
use Facebook ads targeted within a two
mile radius of your shop and then a
different kind of marketing campaign for
the 15 mile radius if you're going into
the delivery of it I think that what you
have to really do is you know I've given
you some tactical stuff off the gate
here are some more high level things
first and foremost you need outrageous
levels of patience it is going to
struggle over the first 12 to 24 months
because in general it's a high friction
area obviously with instacart and Fresh
Direct there's plenty of things going on
where people are thrilled to order but a
family grocer to become an internet
player is it is a tough haul and so
patience I think is going to be an
incredibly important part of your
success as you go through this journey I
would make sure that every bag that you
have at the store has a flier in it with
some sort of creative call-to-action
with a coupon that is online only as
kind of a cherry to drive acquisition I
would also try to make sure your POS put
if sale system at the store is tied in
to the dot-com so that people can use
club cards where you can collect data
there and remark it to them on.com
environment email marketing is going to
be an enormous ly substantial part and
backbone of your success I think a very
strong strategy of what the sell on a
daily or at worst case every other day
basis on your email service is quite
important to muster up excitement and
know
of all do not create friction so make it
valuable for people to join your dot-com
environment don't force them into it and
so those are some of the top-line
thoughts
it's nice when you've done it before
make somebody some of these answers a
little bit easier yeah we started thanks
dave rubin asks snapchat has been
attacked with negative reviews since the
update what are your thoughts on the
move Rubin I think that if you look at
all the moves in the last five years by
Facebook specifically but Instagram
Twitter any platform that is extremely
popular that then has an aggressive move
that feels more Celie and I assume we're
talking about discovery above and kind
of the first main Scream screen
I don't think people realize that people
are always gonna complain right anytime
there's change that is in the benefit of
the business right it's very clear to
people at this point that that screen
that you're seeing discover you didn't
want it there they're forcing me on
discover these are exactly the things
that we saw with Facebook when they did
a hevery update I mean the newsfeed was
one of the first groups to get a million
or ten million Oh number two number at a
time but when Facebook switched from you
go to people you saw everything and
you'd go to people's walls and all those
things I mean this is constant I think
it's a tremendous move by snapchat the
discovery consumption has exploded since
the move have you have used more
discover since the move
Stephan cindy in turn you know my data
shows that 100% of people you know it's
just it's so interesting I mean it's a
tremendous move by snapchat it's making
it more native easier for them to go
into that channel that is the channel
that they are going to monetize and so I
think it's a brilliant move I think
you've got to take some of the heat
early on I think every one of those
people that have complained
have used snapchat quite a bit except
for three rogue hippies and that's fine
because snapchat and Facebook and every
business doesn't give a crap about that
extremism of anti-business because the
numbers don't play themselves out and I
think that um I think that they did not
go too far and I think that they've done
it just right I think they've slowly
introduced it you know first a swipe
over here now they've moved it up here I
think they I'm blown away Evan such a
young CEO and and I'm just really really
impressed I was wrong about story you
know stories I didn't think was going to
be successful because there was that
swipe and I thought that was a friction
and that worked he's really really
impressed me and I'm very very bullish
on on snapchat so much so that in my
Boehner are a see fund I spent the last
batch of money instead of an entire
another year of investing in twenty
thirty more companies I went all in all
was in on snapchat wrote a huge check
biggest check of my career at a fifteen
point sixteen billion dollar valuation
I'm a very very big fan of snapchat
they've blown me away I wish I wasn't on
board wait wait earlier I've been
writing about them for a long time and
talking about them for a long time I
think that not that prediction but that
bandwagon is playing out to be true
and so I don't think they went too far
actually think they played it absolutely
perfect and that's not putting on my
investor hat because one thing a lot of
people don't know is I'd much rather be
historically correct then make a couple
of bucks and so I don't want to look
back at this and be like I was wrong
cat asks how do you continue kicking ass
with work while going through serious
personal crises how do you separate yet
deal with vote you know cat it's
interesting this is a tough question for
me I'm not so sold I really know it the
answer one of things I'm very curious
about and I fancy myself and being very
resilient and things that nature but I'm
very emotional you know going through a
very very how is it worded
a personal crisis a serious personal
crisis for me could be enough to me to
put me in a position where I would check
out from a day-to-day hustle and
business standpoint and really go and
address that whether with myself or
whatever I had to address I often think
about knock on when the bad things that
are conceivable in my life and and how
quickly everybody around me will realize
how little I give a crap about business
in those moments and so you know I've
been outrageously fortunate or
unfortunate depending on how you want to
look at it I lost two of my grandparents
long before I was born I lost my mom's
dad my grandfather before he was a
couple months before he was coming to
America to join us so I don't remember
him so I've only had one grandparent
growing up which created a scenario
where I haven't fortunately had a lot of
death or sickness that's the cliche
thing obviously so many of us not me
thank God but so many of you so many
people here have dealt with crisis is
that I'm Way more intense whether it's
siblings or parents or you know uncle's
or aunts or best friends that they're
close to I've been extremely fortunate
I think I'm driven by that gratitude I
think people are confused by the
gratitude I talked about it's not the
monies it's it's or the the amazing
audience and admiration I get from
thousands it is far more predicated on
the health and well-being of my family
and and dearest friends and so you know
I would I would say as somebody who
pushes hustle 24/7 365 that that is
probably the area where I think you know
outside of actually having to do it to
put food on your table or stay practical
you know I think that is absolutely the
time and place and the permission to
step away regroup have time for yourself
deal with those issues and come back
fresh you know I think that it's a
mental game and and it would be insane
for me to sit here and impose a strategy
without
having all the context so I think it's
different for everybody I think I know a
lot of people that go the reverse and
and go deep into their work to shut it
down my intuition is I'm not that my
intuition and having a lot of
self-awareness is I check out a little
bit and I let all the wonderful people
that I've done a lot of good for as a
leader step up in those days or weeks or
months because I've I've empowered them
to be able to do things you know like
Steve could sit here and be on the show
when you eat a couple of almonds that
kind of stuff
hey Gary saline Johnson here the author
of New York Times best-selling book push
and the creative smart success I am here
on the set filming a little piece for a
fitness infomercial and they're calling
me right now to be miked up I'll be
writing a Zagat talking to Gary Gary the
question for you about Instagram do you
know that there's no two-factor
authentication on Instagram how scary is
that right so you built this like huge
following and somebody could hack in so
easily
I was recently hacked and I would love
to get your thoughts about cybersecurity
and how serious people need to take it
especially those people who are building
an online presence or have passive
income online and how legit how serious
the threat of cyber security is and what
we should do about it we should fight CJ
thank you so much for the sort of the
video you know it's interesting and
maybe just such a positive gal but my
intuition based on the tone of that
video is you got your account back and
so this is my thought on cyber security
and privacy in the same old thing which
is you know the reason nobody cares
about privacy anymore is in my opinion
and this is and I know a lot of you said
what I care a lot about privacy ah you
don't because your actions prove
otherwise
meaning the two things we care about in
this world are money and the health and
well-being of our family family and
money like those are two we care about
other things those are two up there show
me your top five list they matter and
both of those things in the privacy
security world my kid's gonna get
kidnapped
or somebody's gonna steal my money for
my
thank or my ATM or all these things yeah
two things one kidnapping is way down
because everybody is a media company and
everybody's recording and it's just hard
to grab kids at the mall right number
two when you look at money everybody
gets the money back I think what
happened and I I'm going on intuition
and please jump in and tell me if I'm
wrong here but I think you got your
account back
there's your email Facebook or Instagram
they're like cool and so I think it's
it's concerning you could have a day or
a week of a real problem but I think
what they're there's a couple of and and
and I'm worried that people are watching
and think there's a naivete here but it
speaks to an optimism that optimism that
I really believe in I don't think we've
quantified how little cyber cyber issues
there actually are and there's a ton
it's unlimited
put in cyber security cyber hacks put
them into Google News Alerts and your
inbox will be pounded every day there's
HAP this is happening on the flip side
think about what's actually happening
and it's really interesting we've almost
become immune to them right target got
hacked right which was a huge amount of
people you know almost everybody at this
point has been hacked and and what's
interesting is what then happens so so
once you get over the hacking or the
issue at hand you ask yourself what was
the ramifications of that and that's
where you get down a much more
fascinating debate to me which is we're
just on the I mean I'm almost ready to
like shoot out my social security number
here on the show it's perfect 9 for now
not yet but soon enough maybe episode
125 or 521 I'll be ready to shoot out
myself so you know it's funny I used to
say this all the time somebody came up
to me at a conference said you know blah
blah blah did that and got a [ __ ]
head cut off and got all sorts of hack
that was like all right I don't want it
but but only because I didn't want to
deal with the time that you know the
funniest part is the biggest fear I have
in cyber security is time time is where
is becoming so valuable and I think
long-term that becomes a more
interesting debate to me which is you
know the time you have to do
with you know changing this and changing
that and change your password resetting
and emailing everybody and telling them
those are that's the real deathblow and
and so that's bad but CJ I don't think
it's this insanely tough issue
especially because it's a cops and
robbers game meaning I have enormous
belief in the balanced system of cops
and robbers cat mouse meaning the good
guys the bad guys who are the good guys
who are the bad guys all its
conversation I have a lot of empathy and
respect for it I think it's a net-net
game because it's pulling from both
directions and I think we live within
that middle and I think that right now
you're obviously at the height of your
emotion about it because it sounds like
it happened recently but I have a funny
feeling that six months ago it's kind of
a different feeling in your heart and so
you know you might have lost some income
for a day they might have posted
something that embarrassed you or or or
made you leave some fans and then
doesn't allow you to recoup of that max
but again you start on your way back the
next day I just step back some things of
that nature and so that's just kind of
how I see it the bades asks when is it
appropriate to have patience versus just
getting [ __ ] done and not making excuses
you have that problem do you rock yeah
that's a great question and I think that
um it's it's a tough one to answer
because I think every situation has its
own context i I think balance matters
you know I think that you know if you're
being told that you're impatient all the
time from many different sources you may
want to give that some thought you know
obviously I'm a seller of both right get
things done be very patient I think that
a lot of the nice things that have
happened to me are predicated on that
balance I think I talk about balance a
lot the last question I said it here we
are again one question later I think you
need to find your cadence on this issue
I also would recommend
to everybody to the next thing that
happens after this show so is uh is to
is to try to do the one that feels less
natural to just taste the outcome I
think one of the things that is
fascinating to me is how many people
don't test for example yesterday I
posted the the stunwin sit-in no no show
video as a YouTube video not native not
the right move not putting in as a
facebook video which will get us more
reach based on the Facebook algorithm
but I wanted to see what it would do
I was curious about the results I want
to test I think that the lack of testing
the lack of calling your own bluff the
the amount of people that are drawing
lines lines in the sand and then don't
cross them is a huge mistake for example
it was pretty conventional wisdom that
long written out Facebook posts was not
the way to go or people would talk about
that maybe not being native in a jab jab
jab right hook kind of world but then
last weekend by row one and it did
really really well put up another one
did really really well and another one
and another one and here we are four
five six posts in and they do extremely
well because one thing I'm starting to
realize is holy crap
Facebook should be treated like a
website your post should be long
shopping should be done that way like
wait a minute
this is really just the attention and we
are kind of evolving and it's evolving
and so I'm fascinated by the way the
YouTube video got solid reached like it
wasn't so remarkably lower than a native
one it was though and I think you just
never always know but by average but
it's fascinating and I try things and I
try things all the time and I think I
think you know the answer to your
question is the next five things that
are cliche things where you get told at
you're impatient two times you try to be
patient taste it learn taste it
learn taste it learn these are the
things that people don't do enough of
they it's kind of like that you know
it's so interesting so first give me a
bottle of wine Stefan this kind of makes
me think of like the wine world I always
talk about you know like you know the
biggest problem in the wine world is you
find a type of wine you like oh I love
bro
say and you drink it forever and never
try all these other great wines I think
the same thing happens in business you
find your move
right like I'm gonna email marketing I'm
good at sem I'm gonna Facebook I'm gonna
Instagram I'm a good salesman
I make nice videos and you never try the
other things when's the last time you
created an infographic some effect we
need to create an infographic and you
make some notes
we need an infographic ASAP said the
intern because we need to keep pushing
the boundaries as well I need to eat my
own dog food take my own advice we have
to do these things that is the key in
life let alone business and so I love my
excitement on this question because it's
important and because I feel like so
many people don't do it so try things
try things try things because then you
can answer for yourself ones the right
time for patience and when's the right
time to move fast right I mean a
massively senior higher two days ago be
great for vaynermedia mom lately have
been almost saying Wine Library when
Vayner is the second time I've done that
like two or three episodes I made it
very senior high for vaynermedia and in
the meeting with you know the CFO the
CIO and AJ and was like oh you're moving
fast and then other things you know like
I'm being very patient on there's just
always a mix and so mix it up um let's
keep going India this is a rare occasion
where I have something but I want to do
it more
I want to another question I know three
for a loop here and now you probably go
into some incredible India like database
let's call let me go to Twitter and
check the hashtag that's what's this one
Gary Vee lucky asks what do you do in
your free time
or do you even have free time lucky I
have a ton of free time well it's not
free time I mean it's I assume you're
asking what I'm not working I'm spending
it always with my family and then the
only other thing I like to really
allocate time to is the New York Jets
Lizzie and I sometimes watch
documentaries movies that's a fun thing
for me I really like dock use I don't
talk about that so there's that let's
keep going this one let's do a rapid
kind of like I know I know they love the
episodes onder's asks Gary what would be
the best platform to make a virtual
bookshelf with quotes and books that
mean a lot to me
Pinterest yes good job Anders all right
Kenneth asks yo Gary is that next book
coming anytime soon
oh that's oh the book announcement yeah
see you said see see this is what's so
incredible about life and you love this
right you need to write a medium post
about this actually and stop spilling
coffee on yourself let's let's talk
about this this is the first time in a
hundred and twenty four episodes that
I'm like no let's keep going I think
we've done something maybe there's one
other things something said but no this
is really the first time like I'm like
flat-out no let's just keep going
definitely the first time we're going
improv and we are supposed to announce
something very special and now we're
going to so the new book is coming soon
who asked that question
Kenneth thank you for saving the show
we're we have a new book coming a lot of
you know this
Kenneth didn't it's coming out in March
it's called askgaryvee the book and I'm
trying to position it I'm trying to
create the subtitle in a point of like
the modern MBA or like or like the
holistic view of being a business like
like business 2016 and be
like the way to hotel I gotta come up
with a subtitle but I want to give it a
morning that being called askgaryvee
makes it very narrow and you're at the
bookstore and you've never heard of me
like you know so I got to give it a
strong subtitle of like a 360
matter-of-fact anybody want you know
question of the day what should the
subtitle be of the askgaryvee book
I like that somebody's about to really
get pumped here's another way for you to
be a part of the book it's going to be
497 you know answers and this was the
original subtitle like 497 answers on
how to be great at remember a super-long
sac made an incredible cover I'm not
gonna put link it up yet because I'm not
sure it's that but and then it's like an
Amy never before answered questions
which you and I and my ghostwriter Steph
land are gonna be attacking very shortly
I have a feeling some of you want to be
one of those never before asked
questions and answers so we're doing a
competition oh I get to make up the
email address yes so if you email right
up here book questions at vaynermedia
calm that's right
book questions at vaynermedia calm this
is what you will be emailing me the
question right and now that may be a
question that's already used in a book
so India world famous India may be
reaching out to you to like it another
question from you because that one's not
gonna make it but more importantly this
is the gamification this is the
Kickstarter aspect of it this is the
salesman this is the right hook part of
it you have the email blind auction
blind you have to email your name and
how many books you were willing to buy
now because believe it or not it's
actually already on Amazon do not buy it
by the way I know a bunch of you're
gonna be like Gary I already went and
bought it I don't want that yet because
I want to get the cover up there get it
really right and then do a huge push
probably in November and December juice
it up let people discover it so don't
get crazy you can get a little crazy buy
one if you want to but no get there yet
how many books will you buy so literally
let's say d-roc enters hey Gary Vee
you're the best like by the way you look
so
lately you look great I love the show I
haven't missed any of them just super
handsome and massively massively
massively smart you're my favorite okay
here it is I will buy one hundred thirty
seven books here's my question the top
80 or 90 we have to decide we'll decide
very shortly and we'll keep a database
whatever we decide of 87 never before
the top 87 book amounts we'll get into
the book you'll be there from you it
really rad I'm super happy I'll be happy
cuz I have a bunch of books you'll be
happy because you'll give up a bunch of
books for next Easter or something like
that or for your group or your clients
or your friends so that's what it is my
friends join send we will give you some
time here but we will we will be
calibrating those numbers immediately so
see how that worked out
you keep asking questions I'll keep
answering them
[Music]